beim thank you so much for joining me
today tell me a little bit about your
chess upbringing uh thank you Saina for
having me and when it comes to my up
just upbringing it's influenced by my
family by my siblings um my sisters
played chess when they were like 9 10
years old they started it and when I was
around like six seven years old I I
remember watching them play and that got
me interested uh in chess but my brother
was the one who actually taught me how
to play chess when I was three and a
half years 3ish years uh as I was told
so I don't really remember how I learned
how to play chess but I have been
playing chess since I know myself wow
that's that's very nice how many
siblings do you have I have three two
sisters and then one brother okay I
wasn't I didn't know about the brother
so learning you he's the one who never
played chess but he knows how to play
chess and always follows the games my
tournaments and is he the one who taught
all of you to play uh no actually my dad
was the one who told my sisters have to
play and my brother is the third so he
his responsibility was how to was to
teach me how to play so it's only me I
see so you learned around three and a
half four and uh how did you continue
after that was it were you um excited
that your sisters were playing and you
kind of learned from them you wanted to
be stronger or just be able to compete
or I never had such a great like
motivation oh I want to do that I want
to win this tournament it was about
traveling actually I was a crazy kid I
would never sit down and work on
anything I was I loved uh like playing
games with my friends basically it was
totally different Dynamic back then and
the opportunity that we got back in OB
bistan at the time was if you win the
you like national championships by 1 and
a half points you were eligible to go to
a Asian and uh World Championship you're
only you so it was my huge motivation
traveling and going to both of them so I
will try to beat uh everyone like I I
won a lot of my games like that for that
reason and then chess was something very
fun for me I would like you know just
play back I see so you basically were
motivated by the opportunities that
chess gave you to travel and um I'm
assuming you did a lot of work in order
to be able to win all those it's just
like it was the way my uh family uh
motivated me because they knew what I
like and then they knew I like chess but
I couldn't like sit down and work
because at that time I was too young to
understand why I should do that
basically so did you have times that you
were spending together working on CH
playing or maybe studying end games
middle games uh absolutely my oldest
sister she's a wgm and my youngest
younger sister she's a f Master too
she's a quite strong player and they
helped me a lot even my brother he has
he he's a candidate master so it's just
like chess is all around my family and I
worked quite a lot with my sisters until
I reached a point when I you know when I
needed more coaching than working with
them was there a specific book that you
remember as a kid that influenced your
chess not really and when I was growing
up already we had internet we had a lot
of information uh like flowing around I
played it a lot and then we tried to of
course learn from books a lot and in
like end games middle game but still we
didn't have something specific we just
had a lot of material can already I see
and coming to the United States you've
been balancing a professional chess
career with uh going to school tell me a
little bit how you were able to manage
your time and also of course get ready
for this year's us Championship well I
think I didn't manage my time well you
can see from my rating it just dropped
like 80 points 100 points since I came
here the things that um college is a
whole like different experience it gives
you like personal different like you
know growth and I love the process I
still uh do it and I love it and it's a
little bit hard to balance with chest
but slowly I'm come coming back where I
can still do school and I work for the
club little it you know that and I still
enjoy chess so it's more about me
sitting down and doing something but
still enjoying um my time doing chess
learning something new so you enjoy
working on chess but also combining it
to continue promoting our beautiful game
absolutely and I love what you're doing
with the club I love sharing with you
this position Wonder but this time
you're the competitor so I wish you good
luck in this competition thank you so
much for sitting down with me and
looking forward to your games thank you
[Music]
Sabina